[Musik]
millionen menschen sind arbeitslos oder
in kurzarbeit
noch mehr sitzen seit corona im
home-office die pandemie sie hat unsere
arbeitswelt ordentlich verändert die
frage ist zum guten oder zum schlechten
[Musik]
darüber möchte ich jetzt diskutieren mit
folgenden gästen wolfgang grupp
unternehmer und trigema chef johannes
vogel fdp arbeitsmarktexperte karl
lauterbach spd gesundheitsexperte karten
linnemann vorsitzender der mittelstands
union von csu cdu und boris palmer der
grüne oberbürgermeister von tübingen
zunächst möchte ich aber erst noch mal
auf die richtigen fragen der letzten
woche blicken denn da hat cdu-politiker
friedrich merz mit seiner aussage zum
thema kurzarbeit ordentlich für wirbel
gesorgt ist gewöhnen sich ohnehin im
augenblick relativ viele menschen daran
ein leben ohne arbeit zu führen das ist
in der krise richtig nur ich habe diese
woche in einem hotel übernachtet wo
praktisch überhaupt kein personal mehr
vorhanden war
also wir müssen ein bisschen aufpassen
dass wir uns nicht alle daran gewöhnen
dass wir ohne arbeit leben können wir
müssen zurück an die arbeit
herr krupp wir müssen ein bisschen
aufpassen dass wir uns nicht alle daran
gewöhnen dass wir ohne arbeit leben
können eine steile these die hat herrn
merz auch ordentlich gegenwind
eingebrockt diese woche unter anderem
aus den eigenen reihen sogar war zu
hören dass sei menschenverachtend wie
sehen sie es ist das menschenverachtend
oder hatte da möglicherweise einfach
eine unbequeme wahrheit ausgesprochen
also ich möchte man sagen er hat damit
sicher nicht ganz unrecht
ich sag mal die arbeit gehört zum leben
dazu und das merken wir ja auch wenn wir
drei wochen betriebsurlaub haben dann
kommen die leute begeistert wieder
endlich mal wieder gemeinsam zusammen
zur arbeit und man freut sich und ich
sag mal das ist bei uns auch normal dass
man sagt die arbeit gehört zum leben
sowie natürlich auch die grüße freizeit
und das privatleben auch zum leben
gehört ein gewisser mix ist auf jeden
fall ganz wichtig herr linnemann herr
merz ist ihr favorit im rennen um den
cdu vorsitz würden sie sagen sie stimmen
ihm darauf voll und ganz zu oder hat er
damit der aussagen zumindest ein
bisschen daneben gelangt
er hat ja differenziert er hat ja gesagt
wenn wir zu lange das kurzarbeitergeld
laufen lassen dann kriegen wir
offenkundig ein problem und das teile
ich ich hätte das kurzarbeitergeld nicht
bis ende nächsten jahres laufen lassen
weil sie müssen wissen wir machen das
branchenübergreifend der staat übernimmt
100 prozent der
sozialversicherungsbeiträge es wird
mitnahmeeffekte geben
es hätte ausgereicht wenn wir es bis zum
frühjahr hätten verlängern müssen aber
friedrich merz hat auch gesagt in der
krise ist dieses instrument richtig und
wir sehen das ja die welt beneidet uns
und heute gehen wir das geld aus was in
den letzten zehn jahren eingenommen
haben wir geben sogar noch viel mehr aus
und deswegen müssen wir vorsichtig mit
dem geld umgehen
wir können nicht so tun als ob es kein
morgen gäbe er macht das verantwortung
der nächsten generation auf die
verlängerung des kurzarbeitergeldes
würde ich gleich noch mal ganz zu
sprechen kommen aber zunächst noch mal
herr peymann sie die frage ganz speziell
die märz aussage fanden sie die zynisch
oder hat er recht also mehr sein was da
jetzt wieder menschenverachtend dran
sein soll das kann ich überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen
wir müssen doch irgendwie auch nochmal
mit meinungsverschiedenheiten in der
demokratie klar kommen ohne gleich immer
die menschenrechte verachtet zu fühlen
ist verstehe ich überhaupt nicht
inhaltlich bin ich etwas anderer
auffassung merzig klage unser problem
ist nicht das kurzarbeitergeld im
gegenteil das halte ich für eine lösung
weil ich das nur da in den branchen sehe
wo es halt einfach wegen corona keine
arbeit gibt ja also messen finden halt
nicht statt was sollen die leute machen
da ist kurzarbeit genau die richtige
lösung
aber wo ich ein problem sehe ist dass
die insolvenzen dauerhaft verschleppt
werden können weil sie ja derzeit nicht
stattfinden ich glaube muss er von der
seite her denken und wir müssen uns
darüber gedanken machen wie viele
unternehmen die gar kein geschäftsmodell
mehr
jetzt weiterhin verbindlichkeiten
eingehen können die dann nachher
irgendwann bei dritten landen
ich glaube da müsste man mehr darauf
achten aber das kurzarbeitergeld jetzt
zu verlängern halte ich für völlig
richtig
herr lauterbach aus gesundheitlicher
perspektive würde mich bei ihnen mal
interessieren es gibt ja durchaus
studien die belegen dass menschen die
lange nicht am arbeitsplatz waren also
lange abwesenheiten haben durch
krankheiten und ähnlichen dann durchaus
probleme haben um sich wieder zu
integrieren sehen sie da ähnliche
gefahren bei sehr langer kurzarbeit im
sommer war es sich nicht also wir hier
überhaupt angesprochen ist weil wir
haben ja im moment die situation dass
sehr viele leute doppelt arbeiten also
zum beispiel frauen die also quasi am
arbeitsplatz sind in kurzarbeit sind
aber dann gleichzeitig weil die schule
nicht bedient werden konnte für die
kinder klar kommen müssen und daher
haben sehr viele thema
einkommenseinbußen hingenommen und mehr
gearbeitet also ich würde auf keinen
fall würde ich die aussage von herrn
merz teilen dass die menschen sich daran
gewöhnen wenig zu arbeiten das gilt für
die wenigsten und also wir wollen die
arbeitsplätze erhalten auch die betrieb
erhalten von drei finde ich die
maßnahmen die wir getroffen haben
richtig um die werden wir zurecht
beneidet der wichtigste faktor der hier
bei der pandemie also langfristig was
die gesundheit angeht also durchschlägt
sind die erkrankungen selbst die
menschen die sterben diejenigen die
dauerhaft krank bleiben
und übrigens auch diejenigen die sich so
viele sorgen um die zukunft machen dass
sie über diese sorge krank werden wir
wissen dass also haben wir die
vorlaufzeit für die entwicklung von
depressionen und anderen psychischen
erkrankungen eben länger ist aber dass
das eine große welle nach sich ziehen
wird
und wenn wir in deutschland da besser
raus kommen dass viele andere länder
weil wir haben vielen menschen eine
sicherheit geboten die sie anderswo
nicht haben ich habe sehr gute kontakte
in die vereinigten staaten
und dort sieht man das jetzt schon also
die sorge um den arbeitsplatz die sorge
um die wirtschaftliche zukunft das macht
menschen auch krank das darf man nicht
unterschätzen
daher ist das kurzarbeitergeld auch eine
wichtige maßnahme gewesen um die
gesundheit der menschen der arbeitnehmer
aber auch der familien zu erhalten
ich würde gerne einmal die runde
schließen herr vogel und noch mal an sie
die frage stellen geld ohne arbeit auf
dauer gefährdet das die arbeitsmoral
also ich glaube auf der individuellen
ebene nicht weil das sieht man zum
beispiel hat friedrich merz der hat auch
länger keine politik gemacht aber hat
sich offenbar nicht daran gewöhnt keine
politik zu machen das freut nicht jeden
in der union nicht alle sehen das so wie
carsten linnemann aber auf der ebene
macht die regierung hier das richtige
finde ich kann man das schon kritisieren
ja das kurzarbeitergeld ist ein
erfolgreiches kriseninstrument das ist
völlig unstreitig signal wird auch
übrigens überparteilichen konsens
überhaupt in der krise jetzt genutzt und
werde das auch gar nicht so schnell
gegangen wenn wir als opposition nicht
mitgemacht hätten
aber die frage ist ja erstens ist die
regierung fährt und sie behandelt zum
beispiel selbstständige ganz anders als
angestellte die lässt sich in dieser
krise im regen stehen dass das erste von
drei problemen das zweite problem ist
sie verlängert das kurzarbeitergeld
jetzt sehr lange
überraschenderweise bis nach der
bundestagswahl also ob es da um
wirtschafts und arbeitsmarktpolitik geht
oder darum sie über die wahl zu retten
das kann man nun sehr kritisch sehen und
vor allem so kann man sich vielleicht
zeit kaufen so kann man aber kein echtes
wachstum kaufen und was mir zu kurz
kommt sind maßnahmen die die
rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen dass wir
wieder neue arbeitsplätze schaffen dass
wir uns darum kümmern wie entsteht in
den unternehmen ein neues geschäft wie
kommen wir aus der krise wieder raus
krise abfedern ist gut aber müssen die
krise überwinden
stichwort verlängerung des
kurzarbeitergeldes wir haben jetzt hier
schon einige frauen nach falle gehört
aber die bundesregierung hat ja auf
jeden fall bereits beschlossen dass das
kurzarbeitergeld bis ende 2021 also weit
über die bundestagswahl hinaus
verlängert werden soll und wie
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil das
begründet hören wenn jetzt mal die krise
ist die tiefste wirtschaftliche krise in
unserer generation und sie ist noch
nicht am ersten januar vorbei deshalb
ist es richtig dass für die bezugsdauer
des kurzarbeitergeldes von zwölf auf 24
monate verlängern
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir den
zugang zur kurzarbeit bis zum 31 märz
für die unternehmen und beschäftigten
die das brauchen vereinfacht halten
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir für die
beschäftigten und die familien die
länger in kurzarbeit sind dafür sorgen
dass das kurzarbeitergeld auch
wird in der endstufe für die die ganz
lange drin sind auf 80 bzw 87 prozent
herr krupp wie sehen sie aus
unternehmersicht diese verlängerung also
ich sehe die verlängerung sehr pauschal
und damit nicht richtig es gibt hier
unterschiedliche betriebe natürlich wenn
ich sage die hotels oder sonst oder auch
gastronomie waren natürlich ganz anders
in der groner krise zu bemessen als wenn
ich jetzt sage produktionsbetriebe aber
ich sag mal was mich stört ist das
natürlich viele betriebe die jetzt
kurzarbeit selbstverständlich angemeldet
haben und die froh sind dass sie noch
länger kurzarbeit machen können die
schon fordern pandemie große probleme
hatten und da müsste man natürlich
unterscheiden zwischen betrieben die
vorher ihre probleme nicht gelöst hatten
ob die genauso finanziert werden wie
andere die tatsächlich in der krise eben
durch die krise getroffen wurden und
dann muss man aber auch lösungen suchen
das heißt regina ich habe am ersten tag
als mir meine geschäfte geschlossen
wurden 50 prozent der produktion geht
über unsere testgeschäfte und als ich
haben einem mittwochabend gehört habe
vom landratsamt das ab morgen früh alle
geschäfte geschlossen werden müssen habe
ich am nächsten morgen eine
videobotschaft an meine mitarbeiter
heraus gegeben damit das was vorher
angeschnitten wurde nämlich die
sicherheit beim arbeitnehmer auch ist
habe ich gesagt auch in dieser
wahrscheinlich schwersten krise die ich
in meinen 51 jahren nun hinter mich
bringen muss werde ich ihnen die
arbeitsplätze garantieren wenn sie die
anweisungen die wir die wir von oder die
wir machen wenn sie die voll einhalten
und daraufhin waren die leute begeistert
sie haben gesagt okay uns kann nichts
passieren und sie haben mit einer
begeisterung gearbeitet und wir haben ja
dann sehr schnell durch unsere
flexibilität auf masken umgestellt 80
prozent der produktion viel tiefer auf
masten haben nicht eine stunde kurz
gearbeitet und haben im prinzip
überstunden gemacht und auch heute noch
und das passiert natürlich in anderen
firmen auch wenn sie entsprechend
flexibel und wiederum andere lassen sich
kurzarbeit vom staat zahlen was sagen
sie dazu
das ja das ist die aufgabe des staates
dass er natürlich auch kontrolliert auch
wenn man hört dass hier meint es
natürlich nicht ganz in ordnung
und das ist die aufgabe des staates das
auch nicht gießkannen artig das verteilt
sondern dass er natürlich schon überlegt
und vor allem hätte ich nicht bis 21
sondern ich hätte gesagt gut das kann
man jetzt mal um drei monate verlängern
und dann noch mal drei monate aber dass
ich glaube nicht dass wir wir brauchen
unsere arbeitskräfte wir brauchen die
arbeitsplätze und wir brauchen auch die
produktion wieder denn irgendwo wird die
wirtschaft wieder läuft ja wieder herr
palmer sie sind ja als oberbürgermeister
auch arbeitgeber wie sehen sie denn
diese verlängerung also im öffentlichen
dienst kann logischerweise kurzarbeit
nicht gemacht werden
wir hatten durchaus dafür auch anlass im
april konnten wir zum beispiel die
erzieherin wenige erzieher sind auch
aber meistens erzieherin nicht arbeiten
aber die kommunen konnten davon keinen
gebrauch machen
mittlerweile sind bei uns alle wieder
vollständig am arbeitsplatz
zurückgekehrt
wir sind da nicht davon betroffen aber
ich war vor ein paar tagen auf der
mainau
dort sind natürlich jetzt viel weniger
gäste als früher
dort können keine veranstaltungen
stattfinden ist ein betrieb mit vielen
hundert mitarbeitern können diesen
betrieb nur haben retten indem sie
kurzarbeit machen und ich glaube dass
das instrument deswegen angemessen und
richtig ist
und ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen
dass die unternehmen davon leichtfertig
gebrauch machen denn am ende hat man ja
immer noch einkommenseinbußen für die
beschäftigten wenn man arbeit hat dann
wird man doch der arbeit nachgehen
es ist natürlich die kurzarbeit als
instrument in der krise eine sache aber
diese verlängerung über den jetzt doch
schon sehr langen zeitraum hinaus eine
andere wir haben es gerade gehört mutet
doch etwas ja interessant an ein schelm
der böses dabei denkt aber gleich mal
auf einen schlag über ein jahr zu
verlängern über die bundestagswahl
hinaus
herr lauterbach erkauft sich die groko
da möglicherweise so halbwegs passable
arbeitsmarktzahlen am freitag
ich finde das hier viel zu viel mit
unterstellungen gearbeitet wird zum
einen also die
befristung die wir gewählt haben dass
das hier ist auf die bundestagswahl also
erzielen würde seine billige
unterstellung aber warum macht man da
nicht drei monate wie in der
wirtschaftskrise auf dann sagt für die
nächsten drei monate
die unternehmen die wir befragt haben
der und gesagt das hat die sicherheit
dass es aber einen längeren zeitraum
möglich ist wenn sie keine arbeit kann
auch aufträge haben dass sie mit dieser
sicherheit mit einer größeren
wahrscheinlichkeit die krise überleben
könnten das heißt dass kunst also wenn
sie gestatten sie mir dass ich den
eleganten ausführe
also es geht in erster linie darum hier
insolvenzen und zwar also tatsächlich
insolvenzen nicht vorgetäuschte zu
vermeiden und die beratenden unternehmen
die wir gefragt haben gesagt wenn wir
die sicherheit haben dann schaffen wir
dieses jahr sonst schaffen wir es nicht
und ich bin auch nicht der meinung dass
man den betrieben das unterstellen darf
was ich wurde aber nicht ehrlich gesagt
dass seine partei wie die fdp
also hier unterstellt dass die
unternehmen hier systematisch also das
kurzarbeitergeld missbrauchen würden wir
das wird ja indirekt angedeutet sie
sagen indirekt wird doch gesagt die
unternehmen nehmen das kurzarbeitergeld
mit ihm machen einen schnitt damit das
sehe ich so wie japan hat den ich nicht
in jedem punkt auf zustimmung aber
tatsächlich welcher unternehmer macht
sein gerne kurzarbeit wenn es wieder
anders möglich wäre somit also ich
glaube dass an vielen stellen die mit
unterstellungen gearbeitet wird als
jemand der die verhandlungen wirklich
begleitet hat das hat keine rolle
gespielt die bundestagswahl hat wirklich
hier also die sicherheit zu geben über
so eine längere strecke das wurde uns
von führenden
wirtschaftswissenschaftlern geraten und
die unternehmen haben darum gebeten herr
vogel hat sie das jetzt überzeugt aber
das ist doch wahlkampfmanöver nähe ist
ich unterstelle den unternehmen gar
nicht ich bewerte als
oppositionspolitiker die arbeitsmarkt-
und wirtschaftspolitik dieser koalition
so und ich bin thema kenne ich mich ja
nun aus ich war selber mal bei der
bundesagentur für arbeit tätig als
führungskraft ich weiß wie kurzarbeit
funktioniert wir nutzen ja auch
kurzarbeit übrigens nicht nur in
wirtschaftskrisen also es gibt ja immer
wieder unternehmen gegen krisen sind und
man kann einfach feststellen
anders als in der sehr erfolgreich durch
die kurzarbeit abgefederten krise
2008/2009 wird hier eben nicht
schrittweise vorgegangen
das ist
eigentlich die analogie damals man hat
das schrittweise ausgeweitet das wird
hier nicht gemacht sondern man wer
erweitert eben sehr weit aus und was
nicht was mich stört ist dass sie völlig
aus dem blick verlieren erstens wie kann
man bei den unternehmen auch
differenzieren man könnte zum beispiel
die verluste dieses jahres mit den
gewinnen vorheriger jahren noch stärker
verrechnen das haben sich sehr viele
unternehmen gewünscht da waren sie sehr
zurückhaltend das würde sehr zielgenau
den unternehmen helfen wirklich durch ja
aber sehr begrenzt wissen sie so gut
geht
das würde zielgenau den unternehmen
helfen die jetzt wirklich jetzt durch
die krise in der krise sind und vorher
und funktionieren das geschäft haben das
ist ja dann immer die frage die herr
grupp auch aufgeworfen wird und drittens
was völlig außen vor bleibt ist die
frage wo entstehen eigentlich neue jobs
also ich würde schon vom arbeitsminister
und von der koalition erwarten dass sie
den deutschen arbeitsmarkt so gut kennen
dass sie wissen jedes jahr selbst in
guten jahren fällt eine million jobs weg
also selbst in guten jahren
gleichzeitig wird eine million jobs neu
geschaffen deswegen war die
arbeitslosenquote in den letzten jahren
roundabout in den letzten jahren sehr
niedrig jetzt der kaum noch neue jobs
geschaffen die arbeitskräftenachfrage
ist zusammengebrochen auf ein niedriges
niveau seit den aufzeichnungen nicht
hatten und gleichzeitig fallen aber ja
auch weiter jobs weg das heißt sich
gedanken zu machen wo entstehen
eigentlich neue jobs nicht nur was
machen mit der kurzarbeit sondern wir
geben den menschen wieder zusätzliche
arbeit das konnte viel zu kurz wird
unterstellt dass du das nicht gelten
also ja dass ich keine maßnahme ansicht
sie unterstellen tatsächlich also
ehrlich also sie unterstellen dass wir
nicht darüber nachdenken würden wir
können nicht ständig in der pflege
diskutieren über die richtigen maßnahmen
dass sich demokratie in der pflege
beispielsweise in der pflege wollen wir
wollen wir wollen wir arbeitskräfte
aufbauen daher haben wir dort mit
massiven unterstützungen und also mit
zusätzlichem geld wofür wir sogar die
kassenbeiträge erhöht
hahn will jobs geschaffen ich würde da
ist der staat ja auch nur ein
trotzdem sie haben gerade gesagt wir
schaffen keine neuen jobs
für mich sind auch in der pflege
geschaffene neue jobs wichtige neue jobs
das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen nur war
das galt privaten jobs sind was übrigens
auch noch falsch es war die hälfte
dieser unternehmen sind private
unternehmen in der pflege aber ich kann
nicht sozusagen von einer unterstellung
zur nächsten springen
wir haben uns auch überlegt wo jobs
entstehen sollen und gerade in der
pflege weil in der pflege werden würden
mehrbedarf war aber eher verstecken wenn
die kosten der pflege egal vielleicht
lassen wir das mit ihm unterstellen
sondern tauschen einfach
unterschiedliche positionen aus ich mag
geben ein konkretes beispiel gibt
mehrere arbeitsmarktforscher diese seit
monaten auf vorder etwas zu machen was
so wird zum beispiel auch im deutschen
bundestag vorgeschlagen haben nämlich
dass der staat wenn er jetzt
unterstützungsmaßnahmen leistet was er
tut sehr teuer zum beispiel
mehrwertsteuer und so weiter und so fort
dass er bei neu geschaffenen jobs für
zum beispiel ein halbes jahr die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge übernehmen
könnte es sind instrument was ganz
konkret die besten arbeitsmarktforschern
in deutschland in die debatte bringen
was es attraktiver machen würde wenn
jetzt neue jobs geschaffen werden
das wären rahmenbedingungen die der
staat setzen könnte wenn er nicht
ausschließlich auf die kurze reise so
jetzt sind wir ein bisschen von der
kurzarbeit weggekommen ich möchte wieder
darauf zurückkommen und die frage
aufwerfen nicht nur werden hier keine
neuen jobs geschaffen sondern werden
möglicherweise auch unternehmen jetzt
erstmal über wasser gehalten
die schon vor corinna probleme hatten
bei opel hat sich der betriebsrat und
die geschäftsleitung gestern auf eine
verlängerung der kurzarbeit bis
voraussichtlich ende 2021 geeinigt und
das anstatt von entlassungen
kritik gab es kommt unter anderem sagte
autoexperte ferdinand dudenhöffer in
bild es mutet bizarr an das genau jetzt
wo die freiwilligen abfindungsprogramme
bei opel stocken und firmenchef los
scheller mit betriebsbedingten
kündigungen droht die ig metall
gemeinsam mit opel bis ende 2021
kurzarbeitergeld beantragt macht sich da
ein unternehmen das eben schon vor
corinna probleme hatte einen schlanken
fuß auf kosten der allgemeinheit hair
group das könnte man natürlich so
auslegen ich kenne die internas von opel
nicht
aber ich sag mal wenn das so ist ich sag
mal dann ist es erstens mal auch nicht
gerade positiv für opel
denn er hat ja nun die mitarbeiter nicht
abgefunden und die muss dann ein jahr
später abfinden
also ich kann das nicht beurteilen wie
die da das sehen aber wahrscheinlich ist
das eine feine vereinigung eine
vereinbarung mit den gewerkschaften
gewesen dass keine entlassungen sind und
dass die das jetzt zugegeben haben
generell ist eins wir müssen in unserem
produktionsstandort deutschland endlich
von dem wachstum immer mehr immer mehr
immer mehr zu produzieren müssen wir
wegkommen
wir müssen innovative produkte
produzieren die produktpalette ändern
sowie das auto nicht mehr als wie das
bisher war sie schon längst hätte müssen
auf alternative antriebe gehen und so
müssen wir bei trigema müssen wir
praktisch nachhaltige produktionen
machen und da können wir wachstum sehen
wir nicht in stückzahlen sondern in der
nachhaltigkeit in neuen produkt wie
ersetzen produkte und wenn das jeder tut
dann hat er auch nicht plötzlich die
absatzprobleme weil es kann nicht sein
dass im prinzip andere im prinzip voll
beschäftigt sind und gewisse leute
gewisse firmen unter beschäftigt sind
dann legte sind entweder die ganze
branche oder aber wenn einzelne
beschäftigt sind dann liegt es an den
unternehmen und die nutzen natürlich im
moment selbstverständlich die vorteile
dass der staat einige kosten übernimmt
und das ist natürlich nicht ganz
marktwirtschaftlich vor allem wenn sie
schon vor corona wie angedeutet die
probleme hatten und die jetzt auf kosten
corona sich da leichter die probleme
lösen lassen
ich habe einmal herr krupp hat es gerade
angesprochen dass vielleicht doch der
ein oder andere diese hilfen jetzt mal
mitnimmt sehen sie da gefahren von
wettbewerbsverzerrung weil das eine
unternehmen keine kurzarbeit bekommt
andere aber hingegen schon
also da sein unternehmen keine
kurzarbeit genehmigt bekommt dass wir
jetzt ein ganz anderer fall
da würde hier nochmal das argument
verstärken wollen dass zum beispiel
freischaffende künstler die gar kein
arbeitgeber haben weitgehend raus fallen
als erstmal ihre privaten ersparnisse
aufbrauchen müssen bevor dann irgendwann
hartz4 greift da gibt es lücken im netz
aber in den fehlenden den arbeitgeber
kurzarbeit beantragen oder tarifvertrag
das nicht verbietet werden die das jahr
genehmigt bekommen das sehe ich jetzt
kein großes problem das aber natürlich
das kurzarbeitergeld zu verzerrungen für
das es in der marktwirtschaft dauerhaft
so nicht funktionieren kann ist uns
allen klar
da hilft uns aber nur dass er möglichst
rasch medikamente oder halten impfstoff
gegen korona auf den markt bringen dann
können wir wieder zum normalen modus
auch in dieser hinsicht zurück moment
ist es jedenfalls ganz eindeutig so dass
die masse der kurzarbeits anträge von
unternehmen kommt die vor der krise ein
funktionierendes geschäftsmodell hatten
und dass die sich eben ohne kurzarbeit
nicht über diese krise retten können ich
halte den nutzen für größer als die
nachteile dieses zweifelsohne gibt der
nutzen größer als die nachteile sagt
herr palmer damit würde ich gerne zum
nächsten großen thema unserer sendung
dem home office überleiten
denn zu den dauerhaften veränderungen
durch die korona pandemie in der
arbeitswelt gehört die massive
ausweitung von home office zumindest in
vielen bereichen digitalisierung sei
dank zur eindämmung von corona ist das
home office ohne zweifel sinnvoll
doch ist die arbeit daheim auf dauer
mehr fluch oder segen
herr palmer da würde ich gerne noch mal
an sie die frage weitergeben sind ihre
mitarbeiter in der stadt tübingen die
bei ihnen angestellt sind denn aktuell
im home office und wenn ja wie viele
nein derzeit haben wir die meisten
wieder zurück geholt aber natürlich im
april und im mai hatten wir ein großteil
der beschäftigten ins home office ist
geschickt alle bei denen das vom
arbeitsablauf her möglich gewesen ist
und wir haben auch für den fall dass die
zahlen wieder ansteigen würden mit dem
betriebsrat vereinbart dass wir dann
wieder home office zurück
regel veranstaltungen machen und nur
noch ausnahmsweise winzer von der arbeit
her erforderlich ist vor ort arbeiten
wollen also man kann natürlich nicht den
polizeilichen vollzugsdienst ins augen
office schicken das liegt auf der hand
aber bei vielen schreibtisch arbeiten
ist es möglich und ich muss
ehrlicherweise auch einräumen dass das
ein positiver effekt der korona zeit war
denn wir sind im öffentlichen dienst in
deutschland muss man leider zugeben
rückständig was digitalisierung angeht
das in andere länder weiter und bei uns
hat es einen ziemlichen schub ausgelöst
wir haben angefangen von den daten
breiten die jetzt plötzlich möglich sind
bisschen natürlich auch zur software was
da alles eingeführt werden muss eine
menge nachgeholt und ich stehe schon
fest das viele reisen manche konferenzen
die früher selbstverständlich gemacht
wurden dass die auch nach coroner
wahrscheinlich so nicht mehr
wiederkommen werden in der form weil
sich vieles im home office und digital
durchaus ganz gut machen lässt ist das
jetzt nicht alles aber vieles geht
dadurch einfacher das sind positive
effekte zu beobachten
herr lauterbach im home-office so kann
man sich ganz klar nicht anstecken bei
kollegen aber möglicherweise fehlen ja
auch soziale kontakte die man sonst so
am arbeitsplatz pflegt oder so eine
klare trennlinie von arbeitsplatz und
zuhause
wie würden sie es aus gesundheitlicher
perspektive bewährten überwiegend als er
vor oder nachteile überwiegen klar die
vorteile also die zu home offices bisher
sehr viel studienmaterial auch und also
hat sich nicht bestätigt dass der mensch
der im home office arbeitet das er
vereinsamt und das drum beispielsweise
häufiger an depressionen erkranken wurde
oder an angststörungen oder ähnlichem
sondern diejenigen die zu diesen
erkrankungen also neigen die haben
andere risikofaktoren das home-office
trägt dann nicht bei insgesamt war das
home office aus medizinischer sich das
kann man kurz beantworten war es ein
segen und ich sehe das auch so ähnlich
wie japaner wir sind da rückständig
willigen hinterher nicht nur über im
öffentlichen dienst noch in den
betrieben und auch in der forschung
übrigens also und also ich sehe das ja
auch also ich mache derzeit noch ein
bisschen also
home office also wenn ich mal wegen
vorlesungen halten
für kollegen also zusammen mit kollegen
den vereinigten staaten also die
studenten haben sich so schnell an also
dieser art also der vermittlung des
wissens gewöhnt das ist erstaunlich ich
glaube daher dass also das was seine
kultur waren da zu beobachten gib mir
die zehn nicht gesprochen gibt es mit
dem home office keine wesentlichen
probleme
schöne neue arbeitswelt hair group haben
die beiden kollegen ihnen das
home-office jetzt für sie und die
mitarbeiter schmackhaft gemacht
selbstverständlich das verstehe ich auch
man kann vieles im home-office machen
genauso wie im büro
aber wir sind trigema ist ein
produktionsbetrieb und wir haben 1200
mitarbeiter und davon sind nur 35 in der
verwaltung und die und die anderen sind
in der produktion also eine näherin die
muss an der maschine waren sitzen und
die gibt die man das was sie nicht wird
weitergereicht und so weiter und das ist
im home-office theoretisch nicht möglich
dann der stricker der die stoffe
strecken sind auch maschinen die müssen
in die ausrüstung weiter der verbraucher
also dass sie ist da nicht möglich aber
wenn ich dann in die verwaltung gehen
ist es auch bei uns in der verwaltung
nicht möglich weil wir so kurze wege
haben wir sitzen ja alle zusammen und
wenn ich bin ich eine entscheidung
treffe oder einen mitarbeiter eine frage
hat dann kommt er zu mir und es muss
sofort entschieden werden so haben wir
ja auch als erste sozusagen einen ganz
ein betrieb der überhaupt nichts mit
maske zu tun hat innerhalb von wenigen
tagen durch diese schnelligkeit
umgestellt in der fertigung auf masten
und das sind vorteile von denen wir
heute leben wir haben keine aufträge für
morgen sondern wir kriegen täglich die
aufträge und müssen uns darauf
einstellen und da brauche ich alle meine
mitarbeiter die zusammen die zusammen
die probleme die kleinen probleme lösen
damit wir kein großes haben wenn jetzt
ein bewerber zu ihnen kämen
abteilungsleiter in der verwaltung und
sagen würde er möchte gern ein drittel
ungefähr im home office arbeiten hätten
sie dafür verständnis für sie nein ich
habe volles verständnis dass er es will
aber ich könnte ihnen den job nicht
geben weil das wäre unmöglich bei uns
weil wir brauchen die leute konstant
auch wenn ich unterwegs bin auf irgend
einer reise
dann kriege ich eine mitteilung wann ich
wieder da bin will derweil er mich vor
ort braucht und wir brauchen uns
gegenseitig und müssen gegenseitig ganz
schnell das was auf uns zukommt lösen
und entscheiden arbeitsminister hubertus
heil möchte einen rechtsanspruch auf
home office einführen wie sehen sie das
ja gut wenn er das will ich bin ja in
diesem staat zu hause und wenn das so
eingeführt wird dann muss ich sehen wie
ich damit zurecht komme aber ich glaube
dass meine mitarbeiter das gar nicht
wollte weil die guten mitarbeiter die
bei uns sind ja alle leitenden leute
waren ja ehemalige lehrlinge und die
sind ja nichts anderes gewöhnt als dass
sie praktisch im betrieb walten und
schalten und konstant entscheidungen
treffen und damit sich in die positionen
auch hoch gearbeitet haben ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass diese positionen
90 prozent der positionen sagen ich
bleib zu hause denn dann kann er seine
aufgabe nicht mehr machen denn eine eine
produktionsleitung die im büro sitzt die
mussten die muss runter muss da unten
mit den näherinnen was besprechen oder
mussten die zu schneidern oder muss der
stoff man muss in die färberei und muss
das erklären dass mehrere von zuhause
unmöglich herr lehmann hair group hat
jetzt ausführlich geschildert welche
vorbehalte es dann zumindest aus
unternehmersicht gibt wie bewerten sie
denn den plan einen rechtsanspruch auf
home office einzuführen das ist glaube
ich realitätsfremd also ich glaube dass
die arbeitnehmer und die arbeitgeber
zusammen gerne entscheiden wollen
also eben beispielsweise hat mir noch
ein kollege geschrieben alter kollege
vom früheren job mensch ich habe mich so
an das home-office gewöhnt kann mir gar
nicht mehr vorstellen zurück in die
firma zu kommen
es gibt ja leute die machen die zu 100%
home office also ich glaube das muss
arbeitgeber und arbeitnehmer zusammen
entscheiden der kombi nicht als staat
sagen wir entscheiden jetzt wie der
arbeitnehmer zu arbeiten hat also ich
glaube so ein hybrid format glaube ich
wird sich eher durchsetzen also dass man
teil home office macht und ein teil
präsenz nur wenn man mal ehrlich sind
wir reden jetzt alle sehr positiv über
das thema es gibt natürlich auch die
negative seite und in den
geschichtsbüchern in den nächsten 20 30
jahren bin ich mir sicher wird dieses
thema home office als der schlüssel
schlechthin zum neuen arbeiten
wiedergegeben dass es jetzt wirklich so
eine transformation gab richtige
beschleunigung nur fakt ist auch dass
darunter viele branchen leiden nach
ihnen noch mal eine ganz große
wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft hat ja
eine hohe zahl an mitarbeitern im
sechsstelligen bereich die wollten in
den nächsten zwei drei jahren auf bis zu
50 prozent runter im reisebudget
übrigens nicht aus finanziellen kosten
sondern aus zeitmanagement gründen
das heißt wenn 50 prozent weniger fahren
denn frieden ja auch nicht mehr mit der
lufthansa oder mit wem auch immer die
übernachten nicht in einem geschäft zu
stellen die fahren doch nicht mal mit
dem taxifahrer von münchen zum hotel
oder von madrid die ersten auch keine
pommes mehr an der pommesbude was ich
damit sagen will ist heute ist sicher
dass wir die kapazitäten in vielen
bereichen nehmen sie das hotel lesen im
business-bereich in geschäftsbereichen
nicht halten können und das macht es ja
für uns als politik so herausfordern das
ja auch das was herr palmer und andere
eben sagte und der kollege vogel auch
dass wir jetzt zwar brücken bauen müssen
für die wirtschaft aber wir können keine
künstliche wirtschaft erhalten jetzt auf
dauer denn dann wenn klar ist dass
beispielsweise 20 30 prozent der hotels
kapazitäten nicht mehr zu tragen sind
weil einfach die gäste nicht mehr da
sind dann kommt das schlimme erwachen
und deshalb müssen wir jetzt schon alles
tun damit wir die branchen- unterstützen
bei dieser transformation
wirtschaftskrise durch home office
hervorgeht steht da eine reale gefahr
nein das glaube ich nicht richtig ist
ist natürlich total vielfältig werde
über 40 millionen erwerbstätige man kann
das überhaupt nicht alles über einen
kamm scheren es gibt menschen der
produktion die können natürlich nicht
ins home office ist übrigens auch
anderswo wie soll der gehirn chirurg
oder der handwerker im home office
arbeiten das geht nicht bei ganz vielen
wissensarbeitern geht's und wenn wir
ehrlich sind haben wir da glaube ich in
deutschland sondern pendelschlag erlebt
wir waren im internationalen vergleich
sehr weit hinten ganz geringe
verbreitung von home office und mobilen
arbeiten sind wir der korona krise ins
totale andere extrem bekommen teilweise
100% home office in vielen bereichen mit
dann noch homeschooling und home kita
das natürlich auch kein zustand die
fragen wo schlägt das pendel jetzt
zurück und meine these ist in die mitte
und das ist gut weil das wären
modernisierung
schon dass es in mehr bereichen
vielleicht mix gibt ein paar tage ist
man im home office ist ein paar tage
trifft man sich im team und ist
gemeinsam kreativ wir haben mehr
selbstbestimmung ich glaube dass das
schon neues denken ist was gut ist die
spannende frage ist ja was ist hier die
aufgabe der politik die aufgabe der
politik ist doch nicht dass wir
entscheiden als gesetzgeber wo das passt
wo das nicht passt das muss her grob mit
seinen mitarbeitern und andere
unternehmen und ihren mitarbeitern
entscheiden was die politik aber machen
könnte diesmal den rechtsrahmen
modernisieren das seit vielen jahren
überfällig wir haben in deutschland eine
situation das ist heute wenn man im home
office ist das recht sicher gar nicht
geht ohne dass der arbeitgeber richtig
verantwortlich ist zum beispiel auch für
den lichteinfall der heimischen
schreibtischlampe der müsste dann jeder
wohnung aufsuchen und das kontrollieren
das ist die rechtslage nennt sich
telearbeit klingt ziemlich nach den
achtzigern und so ist eben auch die
rechtslage und da gibt's einen großen
modernisierungsbedarf arbeitszeitgesetz
könnte ich auch noch ausführen
seit jahren ist eine flexibilisierung
überfällig andere länder haben das
gemacht manchmal kann man auch einfach
lernen die niederlande haben vor fünf
jahren der reform gemacht haben das
ganze modernisiert und das wär doch
aufgabe der politik und dann können die
menschen entscheiden was passt also noch
viel arbeit für den arbeitsminister in
diesem bereich der länder man ich würde
gern noch mal an sie die frage weiter
geben wenn es denn theoretisch möglich
wäre würden sie es einem
berufseinsteiger raten ins home office
zu gehen oder ist es vielleicht doch
besser wenn der sagt ich möchte karriere
machen ich muss erstmal präsenz zeigen
kann vielleicht auch bei älteren
arbeitnehmern was mir abgucken
also erst mal hat der vogel natürlich
recht es kommt auf die tätigkeit an
aber wenn beides möglich wäre ganz klar
die firma zu gehen ich meine junge
menschen die müssen ihre kollegen
kennenlernen
übrigens auch die sozialkompetenzen die
immer wichtiger werden in dieser
digitalisierten jahr anonymisierten welt
die auch hier und da so eine
ellbogengesellschaft provoziert da
müssen die menschen unter menschen und
gerade junge menschen brauchen soziale
kompetenzen teamfähigkeit
ich meine er grub ist zwar noch ein
gutes beispiel der es geschafft hat auch
im hohen alter hohe verantwortung zu
übernehmen weil eine
personengesellschaft ist somit volle
pulle haftet aber heutzutage ist
leider auch so dass es immer weniger
personen gesellschaften gibt und es gibt
immer mehr management gmbh möchte ich
auch nicht schlecht reden was ich nur
damit sagen will ist dass in zukunft
immer mehr um teamarbeit geht und dafür
müssen die jungen menschen wirklich zur
arbeit gehen um diese sozialen
kompetenzen auch zu erlernen herr
lauterbach droht home office nicht
vielleicht auch zu einer sackgasse für
frauen zu werden weil er möglicherweise
gerade frauen ins home office gehen oder
gedrängt werden mit dem argument da
lässt sich beruf und familie gut
vereinbaren wie sehen sie da gefahren
zunächst ich glaube nicht dass jemand
arbeiten muss im betrieb um die sozialen
kompetenzen zu erwerben also ich hab da
ein anderes menschenbild jemand der
soziale kompetenz hat baut diese
normalerweise auch außerhalb des berufs
auf und wenn ich also wenn jemand
sozusagen seine soziale kompetenz nur am
arbeitsplatz aufbauen kann dann muss man
sich andere sorgen machen der zweite
punkt ist der also ich glaube das
vertrauen natürlich hier gefahren aber
auch möglichkeit sind viele frauen
wünschen der us home office ich sehe
auch nicht den wert ehrlich gesagt von
einer unendlich langen anreise zum
arbeitsplatz was ja heute so häufig der
fall dass man pendelt was also die
umwelt zerstört was zeit raubt wenn die
gleiche arbeit in gleicher qualität oder
zum teil auch in besserer qualität von
zu hause gemacht werden könnte somit man
muss da mit augenmaß herangehen und
übrigens auch die vorschläge von
arbeitsminister high sind natürlich
nicht vor dass also das kann ich nicht
stehen lassen dass das home-office hier
sozusagen verpflichtend eingeführt
werden kann
für berufe wo es nicht geht das war ja
nie der gedanke somit also muss man das
so sehen es muss mit augenmaß gemacht
wird ich glaube dass frauen große
gewinner von diesen also berufen sein
können und dass wir insbesondere also
auch um die wird also um die
wertschöpfung zu halten uns hier dem
internationalen trend anschließen müssen
so das ist die arbeit einfach schlicht
zu teuer und hat nicht die produktivität
wie sie benötigt betreuung deshalb ein
gutes stichwort wenn ich darf weil das
ein beispiel für das ist was ich eben
gesagt habe die modernisierung da könnte
der arbeitsminister mal gas geben und
die koalition machen wir's mal ganz
konkret
an juden beispiel von dem jungen mann
mein büro leiter der iss drei tage die
woche ist der verantwortlich dafür deren
kleinen sohn von der kita abzuholen weil
seine frau da länger arbeiten muss zwei
tage die woche macht sie das und in
berlin schließen die kitas so früh dass
der faktisch mit anreise und sodann 15
uhr an dem tag das büro verlassen muss
wie läuft das an dem tag ganz konkret ab
an den tagen geht der 15 uhr aus dem
büro bei uns holt fährt zur kita holt
den kleinen sohn ab verbringt dann den
abend mit dem die essen zusammen und
irgendwann abends ist der kleine im bett
so 20 uhr 21 uhr und dann macht man
büroleiter noch mal ein zwei stunden
e-mails die dienstliche e mails vorher
war der flug notfällen erreichbar und
abends macht er noch ein bisschen was
was passiert dann zu hause wenn er mit
seinem smartphone dienstliche e mails
liest wenn der 22 23 uhr die letzte
dienstliche e mail nur gelesen hat er
muss nicht mehr geschrieben haben
rechtlich gesehen darf der am nächsten
morgen vor 10 uhr nicht das nächste mal
auf sein smartphone gucken das ist die
rechtslage in deutschland wissen sie was
passiert millionen menschen jeden tag in
diesem land ignorieren dass das heißt
wir gewöhnen uns daran dass gesetze
ignoriert werden weil diese so veraltet
sind
niemand will dass die leute in summe
irgendwie mehr arbeiten oder weniger
pause machen aber da ist so krasser
modernisierungsbedarf dass wir die
aufgabe für die politik aber es gibt
hier viele vorschläge an die spd wie man
darauf auch an die cdu wird aber gern
noch mal die frage mit den frauen auf
kritisierten gerade gesagt es kann also
home office kann eben auch eine chance
für frauen sein
herr palmer wie sehen sie es oft ist
home office ja auch verbund mit dem
verzicht auf karriere und geheilt sehen
sie im home-office durchaus eine art
emanzipations killer
ich würde gerne vogels beitrag
unterstützen wir haben wirklich eine
menge bürokratischen ballast den wir mit
uns rum stecken kann das nur bestätigen
diese zehn stunden regel bis zum
nächsten arbeitstag die ist nicht mehr
haltbar wird auch in der öffentlichen
verwaltung herr krupp wird es freuen
regelmäßig missachtet ja auch bei uns
wird geschafft hair group und da wird
man mit gesetzen daran gehindert ich
kann auch nicht erkennen dass es eine
emanzipation skinner ist ich glaube eher
dass es so ablaufen wird dass man
zeitweise im home office ist eine
zeitweise ins büro kommt nehmen wir mal
an weiß drei tage da und zwei tage macht
und zu hause so teilt man sich die
arbeit ein dann haben wir auch schon
zwei pinsel wege gespart können die
arbeitsplätze möglicherweise doppelt
belegen da gibt es viele große
potenziale auch für den arbeitgeber
kosten zu sparen und für die
beschäftigten des lebens besser zu
organisieren ich würde die vorteile
betonen und ich glaube nicht dass da von
frauen negativ betroffen sind ich kann
da keine emanzipations probleme erkennen
ich glaube im gegenteil das ist ein
zuwachs an flexibilität ist und meistens
ist er für weibliche karrieren von
vorteil
herr krupp wir sehen sie es führt home
office zu mehr oder weniger leistung da
haben jetzt viele vorteile gehört ich
möchte nicht sagen dass die die home
office machen können weil sie die arbeit
ob sie im büro sitzen oder zu hause
da würde ich nicht mal einen eine
meisten leistungsminderung denken
aber die frage ist eben kann er so
effektiv arbeiten denn wenn ich bei mir
sehe auch wenn ich wenn ich im betrieb
bin dann kann ich sehr schnell an
informationen kommen die ich eben bin
ich zu hause bin erst fragen muss und
wissen muss der mann kann mich erreichen
und das ist ganz wichtig und das kommt
ganz auf jeden betrieb an wenn ich
gehört habe dass aber jetzt
beratungsfirmen natürlich die können
natürlich viel leichter home office
massen als ein produktionsbetrieb wo wir
wo wir konstant aufträge rein kriegen
besprechen müssen machen tun müssen
sehen müssen können wir die lieferzeit
einhalten oder nicht also das ist sehr
unterschiedlich zum zusehen was ich
vielleicht noch anmerken möchte ist der
arbeitnehmer glaube ich den wir ja
mehrheitlich haben wir haben ja
produktions arbeitnehmer
ich glaube dass die auch natürlich gerne
mal in den betrieb gehen um auch zu
hause mal rauszukommen und im prinzip
wenn sie mal mit dir mit der frau
gestritten haben oder umgekehrt dass sie
einfach mal wieder an ihrem arbeitsplatz
kommen wir haben ja gerade 100 jahre
gefallen und diese betrieb ist und die
betriebs familie die betriebs familie
ist er bei uns ein ganz großer wert und
die will audi sind stolz dass sie zu der
betriebs familie gehören und kommen in
die firma und wenn wir betriebsfeste
feiern das ist für die ein highlight das
heißt diese zusammengehörigkeit und
nicht konstant isoliert seien nur zu
hause sein und das sehen wir auch wenn
ein
mal etwas länger krank war dann kommt er
und sagt mir dann irgendwann ach ich bin
so froh dass ich wieder arbeiten darf
dass ich wieder in der gemeinschaft drin
bin und ich glaube das sollte man auch
etwas berücksichtigen dass die arbeit
der nicht nur negativ zu sehen ist und
als ballast sondern dass die auch viel
freude macht denn erst wenn man mal
keinen arbeitsplatz mehr hat und im
prinzip sozusagen zuhause sitzt dann
weiß man was man wie schön es ist wenn
man einen gesicherten arbeitsplatz hat
und jeden morgen gesund zum arbeits und
zum arbeiten gehen darf also wir haben
jetzt hier viele seiten des home office
beleuchtet ist die meinungen gehen
durchaus ein wenig auseinander
deswegen würde ich gerne auf unser
drittes thema zu sprechen kommen und den
blick in diese woche richten richtungen
dienstag an dem die kanzlerin wieder die
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidentin zum corona gipfel
empfängt der grund sind die wieder
gestiegenen infektionszahlen und da an
sie herr lindemann die frage worauf
sollte sollten die verhandlungspartner
am dienstag besonders achten aus sicht
des mittelstands und der wirtschaft was
ist wichtig was würden sie mit geben für
die verhandlung am dienstag
also wenn sie mich so konkret fragen
zwei punkte erstens wir haben bis dato
keine lösung keine adäquate für die solo
selbstständigen in deutschland
die gehen praktisch leer aus so ehrlich
muss man sich machen die sollen hartz 4
beantragen aber das hat ihr system ist
nicht für solo selbstständige gemacht
das half ihr system kennt kein
betriebsvermögen es kennt nicht die
altersvorsorge die vielleicht ein solo
selbständige hat jetzt versuchen wir
wieder daran etwas zu ändern ich setze
mich seit wochen und monaten dafür ein
das ist eine adäquate unterstützung gibt
es nur solo selbstständigen ständige und
ich finde dieses thema muss am dienstag
auf die agenda
erster und zweiter
ich meine klar ich rede jeden tag meine
ich wirklich vorsichtig aber mit der
intensivstation der deutschen wirtschaft
mich rufen messebauer an mich rufen
schausteller an die kriegen da zum teil
gänsehaut was sie den sagen nicht
hoteliers an die reisebranche richtig in
der breite und was mir alle sagen und
vielleicht dass auch ein appell an der
lauterbacher ohne dass es sofort
hochgeht
lauterbach ist geologe und fachmann er
ist aber auch politiker und er weiß das
ist auch die andere seite der medaille
geht und es ist alles richtig und ich
finde auch dass deutschland richtig gut
durch die krise kommen nur wir dürfen
keine angst macherey in deutschland
verbreiten auch keine keinen keinen
alarmismus
ich glaube dass deutschland weiß und die
menschen auch dass wir verantwortung
übernehmen müssen wenn aber
beispielsweise abends nur die
infektionszahlen veröffentlicht werden
ist das schwierig sondern die müssen in
zusammenhang gesetzt werden also was ich
damit sagen will ist ich erwarte am
dienstag klare vorgaben legen wir auch
klare vorgaben für die frage wie ist das
mit privaten feiern weil wir genau
wissen bei privaten feiern gibt es die
probleme übrigens nicht draußen
deswegen müssen weihnachtsmärkte und so
weiter stattfinden da kann man auch
gerne hart sein bei den privaten sachen
aber ich möchte nicht dass dieses land
in angst versetzt wird sondern dass die
eigenverantwortung des einzelnen
gestärkt wird unter den chor ohne
bedingungen die wir kennen
herr lauterbach ich konnte es beobachten
sie sind jetzt nicht hochgegangen
wir haben jetzt die sorgen der
wirtschaft gehört die kanzlerin spricht
trotzdem davon die zügel wieder
anzuziehen
würden sie ihr dabei pflichten und sagen
wir brauchen möglicherweise eine
obergrenze bundesweit für familienfeiern
beispielsweise oder an der masten
pflicht im freien
ja auf jeden fall zunächst einmal zur
korrektur ich bin kein theologe
wenn man so ein epidemiologe aber
nichtsdestotrotz also ich glaube dass
man vorsichtig sein muss dass man
denjenigen die jetzt warnen und konkrete
vorschläge machen was zu tun dass in den
nächsten wochen dass man den alarmismus
unterstellt das ist falsch also wir
wollen einfach schlicht dass wir diese
verhältnisse die wir jetzt in vielen
umliegenden europäischen ländern schon
sehen die wir noch abwenden können wir
wollen dass du das nicht bekommen dafür
kämpfen wir
und dafür muss man auch ein stehen denn
wenn wir das nicht tun dann sind wir in
zwei oder drei wochen genau da wo jetzt
frankreich ist und ganz einfach
ausgedrückt es ist ganz klar also wenn
wir hier beispielsweise acht oder 10.000
fälle in ein paar wochen pro tag hätten
neue fälle
das erste was in die knie gehen wenn die
wirtschaft ist ganz klar das ist also
wer geht dann noch in ein restaurant
wirklich dann noch auf einen
weihnachtsmarkt sind wir dazu aufrufen
würden die weihnachtsmärkte zu besuchen
wird das kein normaler mensch tun
natürlich
daher haben die studien ja auch alle
gezeigt dass was ja mal die wirtschaft
in die knie gedrückt hat war die
verbreitung des videos es war nicht die
maßnahme und das gegeneinander
auszuspielen ist gefährlich wir wollen
einfach ein paar leute versuchen das
hinzubekommen dass wir diesen abstieg
den wir derzeit beobachten also zurück
in die pandemie dieser abstieg gehen wir
jetzt beobachten in spanien in
frankreich in england den werden israel
schon gesehen haben wir wollen das
verhindert und das ist legitim das
machen wir in erster linie für die
gesundheit der menschen und in zweiter
linie auch für die wirtschaft und die es
auf ihre frage zurückzukommen natürlich
wäre es recht handelt natürlich wäre es
richtig bei den privaten feiern einer
obergrenze zu setzen ich persönlich
würde sogar so weit gehen 25 leute
maximales hätte zwei vor
zum einen sind dann die für die 80
prozent also neue fälle verantwortlichen
super splatter ereignisse sehr viel
unwahrscheinlicher
und zum zweiten ist noch viel wichtiger
ist die super bei der ereignisse wenn
die miteinander verbunden sind bei einer
person die hier war und da war also die
sind ganz besonders gefährlich und
diesen effekt haben wir es in den
letzten monaten epidemiologische
untersuchungen können diesen sogenannten
pakula zions effekt den könnte man mit
einer begrenzung der feiern auf 25 leute
und weniger gut in den griff bekommen
das schützt die menschen das schützt die
wirtschaft und das schützt uns auch für
viel drastischeren anderlecht im freien
die masken pflicht im freien ist auch
sinnvoll dort wo ich den abstand halten
kannst stichwort hasen heute hier in
berlin
lautern eng beieinanderstehen brüsseler
platz in köln am stachus in münchen wenn
dort eine masken pflicht also eingeführt
wird wenn die leute auf engstem raum
aufeinander stehen dass das kaiser an
belebten plätzen an belebten plätzen wo
die abstände nicht heiraten können nicht
in allgemeinen freien niemand plädiert
wirklich vorne masken pflicht also wenn
ich jetzt was haben wir durch die stadt
spazieren sondern auf diesen plätzen wo
die leute sich ballen auf engem raum und
wenn man dann eng zusammen entspricht
man laut dieses laute sprechen auf engem
raum das ist ein problem
ministerpräsident markus söder hat einen
vorschlag gemacht eine sogenannte ampel
da sollen dann bundeseinheitliche
maßnahmen gelten sofern corona werte
erreicht sein herr lindemann was halten
sie von dem vorschlag
bildung etwa gerade die verbindung
schlecht ich finde entweder ja nochmal
mit diesen punkten habe ich überhaupt
kein problem und die ampel ist ja auch
klug und ich finde es übrigens auch klug
dass man sagt wir werden national kein
staat mehr erleben bin ich auch der
festen überzeugung sondern höchstens
lokal das sehen wir ja jetzt was in hamm
passiert mir geht es einfach um den
punkt
das ist in deutschland auch andere
bereiche gibt nämlich die andere seite
der medaille
es gibt ganz viele branchen die sehen
kann ufer und die kommen nach berlin und
sagen wir wollen eigentlich keine
subvention wir möchten einfach dass die
eigenverantwortung des einzelnen
gestärkt wird das keine angst gemacht
wird dass es keinen alarmismus gibt das
wir natürlich die regeln einhalten und
xl lauterbach hat völlig recht dass die
leute dann auch nicht kommen wenn wir
jetzt im heim etwas ausspricht dass die
leute dann auch nicht ins restaurant
gehen aber auf der anderen seite würde
ich mich wirklich freuen wenn wir
versuchen mit zuversicht an diese sache
zu gehen natürlich immer klaren regeln
und gerade bei den privaten feiern bin
ich auch gehe also bin ich auch habe ich
überhaupt nichts dagegen wenn man hier
eine stringente auch eine schärfere
lösung macht weil das was wirklich auf
engsten raum passiert mit viel alkohol
ist gefährlich aber alles andere gerade
was draußen passiert ob weihnachtsmärkte
ob andere dinge glaube ich müssen wir
alles zu lassen und wir sollten auch den
bürgermeistern den landräten mut machen
diese veranstaltung auch wenn es kälter
wird zuzulassen natürlich unter
hygienebedingungen herr lauterbach
einmal noch kurz an sie die frage was
halten sie von der syna ampel
ich bin sehr oft der gleichen meinung
wir sünder aber hier stehe mich nicht zu
und zwar schlicht und ergreifend deshalb
überall also eine grüne ampel ist in der
pandemie das falsche signal das gibt das
signal wenn ich jetzt sagen wir dann
landkreis habe grüne ampel ihr könnt
leben dass wenn alles normal wäre das
ist einfach falsch
das ist eine falsche sicherheit in die
wilden menschen also hier bringen
ich glaube dass das ganze symbol einer
ampel nicht grün gelb und rot dass das
nicht in die zeit passt und es muss auch
dann sehr sehr komplex erklärt werden
von daher ist einfach dieser fokus auf
die zahl der neuinfizierten der markt
primitiv klingen derselben logisch ist
da sehr sinnvoll weil an der zahl der
infizierten und an deren
altersverteilung weiß ich wer in vier
bis sechs wochen sterben wird
er kommt also generell bin ich der
meinung wir sollten die zuversicht den
leuten nicht nehmen wir sollten positiv
denken aber wir sollten gleichzeitig an
die verantwortung des einzelnen ab
leon man sagen je schneller wir je mehr
er die verantwortung übernimmt für das
tun was er macht desto schneller können
wir die pandemie sozusagen einschränken
oder überwinden und das muss mehr heraus
gesetzt werden so wie wenn ich von hamm
sprecher und die hochzeit da ist eben
der rahmen überschritten worden man hat
eben mehr gäste eingeladen und das darf
nicht sein wir müssen jetzt kurzfristig
die verantwortung übernehmen und so uns
verhalten wie das dir für die die
experten vor geben damit wir im prinzip
keine höheren steigerungen der
krankheiten haben und die pandemie
irgendwann dann in kürze auch überwinden
und das ist jetzt was sich von der
deutschen bevölkerung wünschen dass wir
alle die maßnahmen einheiten sie haben
jetzt aber die chance noch einmal einen
appell auch an die kanzlerin zu richten
was wünschen sie sich als unternehmer
von diesem gipfel am dienstag ja gut
wenn man mich fragt ich verlange die
verantwortung zurück in die betriebe
auch ich sag mal die betriebsinhaber die
verantwortlichen haben die verantwortung
auch die arbeitsplätze hier zu halten
oder auch entsprechend zu entscheiden
und vor allem nicht immer gier und
größenwahn heute alles aufkaufen und
morgen alles hinschmeißen man soll
verantwortlich handeln und deshalb
sollte mehr die haftung wieder zurück in
unsere gesellschaft das
wirtschaftswunder nach dem krieg ist
geschaffen worden von lauter persönlich
haftenden unternehmen heute ist das ganz
anders man hat es ja vorhin schon gehört
es gibt praktisch kaum noch eine haftung
und damit wird entschieden geht es gut
wird kassiert geht schlecht dann
schmeißt man den bettel dem start hin
so kann es nicht sein wenn es schlecht
wird müssen die leute in der haftung
sein dann werden sie anders entscheiden
und vor allem nicht gier und größenwahn
konstant walten lassen herr vogel die
fdp wird am dienstag nicht am
verhandlungstisch sitzen was wünschen
sie sich von diesem gipfel ist ich hätte
zwei wünsche und die verbinden
vielleicht auch ein bisschen die themen
werden heute viel über die arbeitsmarkt
in wirtschaftspolitische dimension der
krise geredet erstens ich als
interessierter hörer zum beispiel auch
das podcast von r drosten habe ich
gelernt in den letzten monaten die
bedeutung der aero sohle
also wenn luft sich im raum neben der
der der tröpfcheninfektion wo der
abstand hilft sich verbreitet und das
wird vom winter natürlich schwer weil
und für viele branchen die schon mal
jetzt ein schwierig
die restaurants also überall wo zum
beispiel geschlossene räume sind das
wird natürlich wenn es kälter wird mit
dem lüften immer schwieriger und neben
der diskussion draußen würde ich mir
etwas wünschen was wir zum beispiel
nordrhein-westfalen mal diskutiert haben
so eine art innovationsklausel in den
verordnungen also wenn zum beispiel eine
unternehmer investiert in die neue
technik von luftfiltern die da die aero
sole aus der luft herausfiltern
das dann zb er auch innenräume wieder
stärker nutzen kann in seinem restaurant
sofern die abstände eingehalten werden
dieser aspekt der würde wirtschaft
innovation sozusagen im kampf gegen das
virus technische innovation und
wirtschaftliche abfederung verbinden das
tut mir noch zu wenig diskutiert zweiter
punkt ich will es beliebt weil es mir
wirklich wichtig ist ich will absolut
unterstreichen dass carsten linnemann
gesagt hat ja ich würde mir endlich eine
lösung für die selbstständigen wünschen
aber da reicht es nicht dass muss ich
leider so hart sagen so gern ich karsten
mark und so gute kollegen wir auch sind
da reicht nicht den cdu politiker das
immer in talkshows sagen seit der ersten
verlängerung der ersten nutzung des
kurzarbeitergeldes überhaupt für die
krise habe ich im deutschen bundestag
gesagt liebe leute vergesst die
selbstständigen nicht ihr verändert die
regeln für die angestellten und bei den
selbstständigen sagt er
dann sollen die doch auf jobcenter und
ich höre immer wieder dass cdu-politiker
und talkshows tagen zwischen helge braun
letztes jahr da müssen wir eine lösung
finden bei der alt macht immer da müssen
wir eine lösung finden ja wer stellt
denn die regierungspartei die die
kanzlerin stellt dann findet endlich
eine lösung haben heimlich sie noch mal
die frage was ist aus sicht der kommunen
wichtig für die maßnahmen die am
dienstag getroffen werden wir sollten
die alten besser schützen die menschen
die möglicherweise an corona sterben
sind im schnitt 82 jahre alt in
deutschland gewesen auch in anderen
europäischen ländern
wir haben deswegen entschuldigen damit
begonnen das personal in der altenpflege
alle 14 tage zu testen auf corona damit
wir sicher sind dass dort nicht
unerkannt infektionen in die heime
getragen werden denn wenn im heim des
virus mal grassiert wenn es dort zu
einem ausbruch kommen dann gibt es eine
sehr hohe todesrate und deswegen würde
ich mir wünschen dass das verbindliche
ganz deutschland eingeführt wird im
moment zahlen werde aus der tüte war
kassel weil uns die alten menschen das
wert sind wenn die infektionszahlen
weiter steigen sollte man es vielleicht
sogar jede woche machen
ich bin mir auch ziemlich sicher dass
die infektionszahlen steigen werden
nicht nur wegen des winters sondern weil
mein eindruck ist dass niemand mehr alle
kitas und alle schulen schließen will
und wir haben jetzt schon in baden
württemberg 180 klassen in denen fälle
aufgetreten sind
wenn man also dieses bildungssystem
weiterlaufen da bin ich sehr dafür ich
glaube es war falsch ist noch mal zu
machen
dann müssen wir einen weg finden wie wir
infektionen war der jüngeren bevölkerung
eingrenzen und das übergreifen auf die
älteren stoppen
deswegen gibt es in tuttlingen zb parade
taxen für die älteren damit sie nicht im
schulbus mitfahrer müssen deswegen haben
wir auch vorbereitet dass einkaufszeiten
für die senioren reserviert werden dass
sie die möglichkeit haben ohne die immer
mehr menschen die infektion haben werden
im geschäft zu sein solche möglichkeiten
gibt es und die sollten wir stärker
nutzen also das risiko einer schweren
erkrankung zum maßstab unseres handelns
machen das vermisse ich den corona ist
in deutschland für 99 prozent seit mai
für 99 prozent der menschen die
infiziert wurden sehr glimpflich
abgelaufen viele merken es ja gar nicht
wir müssen endlich dazu kommen dass wir
das risiko einer schweren erkrankung zum
maßstab unseres handelns machen danke
herr palmer damit kommen wir auch schon
zu unserer abschlussrunde denn wer die
hat bundesweite warnstreiks angekündigt
im öffentlichen dienst die forderung 4,8
prozent mehr geld für 2,3 millionen
beschäftigte und jetzt wirklich eine
schnelle abschlussrunde ist das
berechtigt oder unverantwortlich herr
lauterbach so eine tarifforderung und
eine tarifforderung ist immer berechtigt
weil wir haben die tarifautonomie
ob sich das dann nachher so durchsetzt
das werden wir sehen
aber wir politiker geben doch nicht die
tarife vor
somit steht es mir nicht an also mich
dazu zu äußern aber die forderung ist
auf jeden fall nachvollziehbar und das
werden wir die verhandlungen abwarten
streiks in der korona pandemie hair
group gut ich sag mal ich habe natürlich
kann verständnis dass manche bereiche
sagen sie müssen schwer arbeiten und sie
wollten eine entsprechende lohnerhöhung
auch wir haben im textilen jahr jetzt
eine
anhörungen wieder gehabt habe erster
september aber vor allem hat mich
gestört in dieser geschichte dass die
politik gesagt hat sie können sie müsste
da kurz treten weil die kassen leer sind
und dass die kassen leer sind da ist
natürlich auch viel unrecht geschehen es
sind millionen und milliarden sind im
prinzip von den unternehmen vergeudet
worden schon vor der korona krise und da
ist kein einhalt geboten worden wenn ich
an karstadt denke dass sein kaufhaus
könige konkurs machen das versandhaus
könige konkurs machen problemlos und
dann wieder weitermachen und das auch
bei der lufthansa ab zuerst hat man
alles aufgekauft und am und am schluss
jetzt weiß man es wieder nicht wie man
es machen soll
man sollte ein bisschen wieder mit maß
und ziel und vor allem mitverantwortung
gewisses wachstum nehmen und nicht
einfach nur kaufen weil man jetzt größer
werden will und dann am schluss hat man
die probleme und da werden viele
steuergelder kaputt gemacht und dann
wären die kassen nicht leer wenn das
vorher alles beachtet wo herr vogel ganz
kurz was sagen sie den streiks ich bin
nicht immer einer meinung mit karl
lauterbach eigentlich fast meist fast
immer nicht aber in dem fall ja ich habe
mir angewöhnt als arbeitsmarktpolitiker
nicht tarifforderung zu kommentieren
weil das ist nicht unser job als
gesetzgeber herr lindemann möchten sie
kommentieren
ich sehe das so wie er vogel und der
lauterbacher sagen sie mir trotzdem eine
private meinung sagen also vielleicht
sollte man ein bisschen sensibel sein
gerade in den bereich wo eltern arbeiten
gehen wenn man jetzt gerade bei den
kitas wieder streikt das finde ich ein
fatales signal für diese eltern die sind
auch finde es ist für viele eltern in
deutschland wirklich nicht einfach im
moment familie und beruf unter einen hut
zu bringen wenn die kita ist jetzt
wieder schließen nachdem lockdown dann
sind die richtig aufwärts inne
aber noch mal herr vogel hat recht unter
lauter brauch wir halten uns als
politiker raus aber dieser private sein
doch erlaubt sind der direkt betroffenen
noch ganz kurz was sagen sie zu den
warnstreiks
stimmt ich bin nicht politiker sondern
der arbeitgeber in dieser frage und für
uns um 4,2 prozent sicher zu hoch
aber normalerweise einigt man sich ja
dann auch irgendwohin damit
ich finde den warnstreiks zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt wirklich schwierig
insbesondere in den kitas da würde ich
mir wünschen dass man erstmal
ausverhandelt streit zeit zum streiken
wir ja dann später immer noch warum
gehört viele verschiedene meinungen zum
thema kurzarbeit home office und auch zu
den warnstreiks das waren die richtigen
fragen sonntagabend ich wünschen noch
einen schönen abend uns gibt's auch
nächste woche an dieser stelle wieder
[Musik]